hey there townscapers
today i want to show you the tour for
the first chapter for connecting small
towns
tomorrow i'll start chapter 2 which i'm
excited about because i started playing
with garden paths
this series is pretty much just me
connecting small towns while practicing
or
experimenting to see what happens and i
guess just showing my evolution through
gameplay in a way
so you'll be seeing me gradually improve
throughout this series if you have seen
some of my footage
this video will feature some buildings
that you may recognize from sessions
three through five
if you haven't seen them or just want to
view them again the playlist will be in
the card in the upper right corner of
this video
along with my random clicking playlist
which is also something that i love
one of the reasons i enjoy this game so
much is because the possibilities are
endless
if you haven't seen my random clicking
series you can see the first challenge
video linked below
i posted it on last thursday i believe
the 28th and i just thought it would be
really nice and then i saw another
townscaper post theirs
about two or three days later and i was
so happy to see
that i inspired them to try this
challenge and just see what comes up and
the results were pretty cool
it's really fun to do and it can be
quite therapeutic if you want to try it
out i encourage you to do so because it
makes for one-of-a-kind builds and i
would love to see what fellow
townscapers create
anyways that's all for me please enjoy
this video please make sure you like and
subscribe because it helps me out a lot
and thank you so much for viewing and
i'll see you next time
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank god david hello we need your help
michael is everyone okay
oh well i'm afraid not
[Music]
i
[Music]
so
[Music]
you